on va voir qui gagnent entre booba et
matthieu delormeau bien sûr de moins
souffrir verrait la chaux je suis
preneur de leurs monnaies papier souffre
allez les gars son mental
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous connaissez personne de l'équipe non
non on avait envie de les connaître moi
ni qu'il est sympa même de leur mot
d'ordre on vous le connaissiez pas
j'avais déjà vu j'ai vu les preuves du
gange et batirov c'est pas possible et
du bol parce qu'on ne l'a pas fait
aujourd'hui l'épreuve a gelé
[Applaudissements]
en plus tous les deux on a on a un point
commun
vous avez de nombreux clashs et moi
aussi
c'est vrai qu'on déclenche en commun je
crois ouais il va dire qu'il ya des
choses car on a en commun
voilà on a également passé tout à part
ça moi j'ai hélène rollès et les
méchants les élèves d'hélène et les
garçons
hélène d'hélène et les garçons s'est
clashé avec moi de ouf voulais me pète
avec alain delon eux vous voulez pas là
de long non moyens et arthur aussi
qu'ils se cachent beaucoup avec moi
voilà donc le vous l'avez pas aussi le
ramène pas des ennemis rejet le temps
qu'il n'en voulait il ya la fouine year
of yaccarini siaap en classe avec la
foule c'est fini maintenant je suis pas
au clash avec la fouine et j'aime bien
il va nous voir c'est parfois ça va
mieux la fouine ou pas ça va aller mieux
ouais je sais pas ce qu'il devient non
mais mais monsieur booba moi c'est non
merci
l'album là
[Applaudissements]
mais on va de l'émission le gars c'est
le conseiller bancaire député coûté
monsieur booba booba contre mathieu
delormeau booba voici ton poids matthieu
delormeau attention vous devez rester
quoi ton record bras tendu comme ça
encore il s'appelle rohff bras tendus
[Applaudissements]
est vrai aux attentions et va calmer
tout ça merci d'avoir été avec nouba
j'espère que vous allez gagner sinon
c'est casser la tête pendant six ans il
me donne mon de perdre et qui perdra
jamais attention à ce que vous pouvez
pour s'entraîner mais ce qu'on peut vous
sent très souple et merci mon basque au
bout et bien là près de lui attention
c'est parti
bras tendus a donné partie 3-2 à top
l'eau loin plus haut plus haut le bras
euro le bras lourds un peu c'est lourd
ça vous va tu me dises ils ont fait
sombrer se concentrer juste après je
contiens film c'est quoi le film en
régie après russian war iii ça va faire
un carton ça a trop bu en plus ce n'est
pas vu non et bah au bout un ch'ti si on
pas pour le diffuser
on va voir qui gagnent entre booba et
matthieu delormeau bien sûr de moi
s'offrir vers nlh au jeu sur une
structure de leurs monnaies pas bien on
fera
allez les gars son mental
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]